عشيه محدثات حاسبه بين الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن وزعماء الجمهوريين بشان رفع سقف
الدين العام قالت وزيره الخزانه الامريكيه
جانت ان عدم رفع سقف الدين العام سيتسبب
في عدم قدره الولايات المتحده على تسديد
ديونها واضافت في لقاء مع محطه تلفزيون اي
بي سي ان فشل الكونجرس في رفع سقف الدين
الامريكي بحلول الاول من يونيو سيحدث
عواقب اقتصاديه في السوق الماليه
اذا لم يرفع سقف الدين فستجد وزاره
الخزانه نفسها في وضع لا يمكن فيه دفع
مستحقاتنا في الاول من يونيو وستكون هذه
المره الاولى في تاريخ الولايات المتحده
التي نفشل فيها في سداد المدفوعات
المستحقه وهذا سيتسبب بفوضى ماليه
واقتصاديه حيث ان سندات الخزانه الامريكيه
هي الاكثر امانا في النظام المالي العالمي
واخفاق الولايات المتحده في سداد ديونها
من شانه ان يثير التساؤل عن اهليتنا
الائتمانيه من المحتمل ان نرى عواقب
اقتصاديه في السوق الماليه اذا لم يتحرك
الكونغرس سريعا
ينضم الينا لان من عشره المراسله الجزيره
عبد الفتاح فايد اهلا بك عبد الفتاح يعني
الى اين تتجه هذه القضيه وهذه المحادثات
الحاسمه بين الرئيس بايدن وزعماء
الجمهوريين في الكونجرس وعن اي عواقب
اقتصاديه يتم الحديث الان
عواقب فادحه ايمان وفقا لما يدلي به
المسؤولون الامريكيون من تصريحات هو في
الحقيقه جرس انذار من وزيره الخزانه
الامريكيه جانيت
بشان ما يمكن ان يحدث من ازمه اقتصاديه
عالميه ومن فوضى عارمه في الاقتصاد
العالمي في حال لم يتم حل هذه المشكله
ازمه قد تبدو جميع الازمات الاقتصاديه
العالميه التي مرت على العالم من قبل مجرد
نزهه الى جانبها سواء كان ذلك ازمه الرهن
العقاري عام 2008 او حتى الازمه الحاليه
المتعلقه برفع معدلات التضخم بسبب ارتفاع
اسعار الفائده العالميه وايضا حتى ازمه
الاقتصاد العالمي عام 1930 والتي كانت
بسبب الركود الاقتصادي وزيره الخزانه
الامريكيه تقول انه سيكون لاول مره في
التاريخ تواجه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
والحكومه الامريكيه ازمه ثقه تواجه حاله
عدم قدره على او التزاماتها الماليه مع ما
يمكن ان يترتب عن ذلك من
انخفاض للتصنيف الائتماني للمؤسسات
الامريكيه ربما ايضا اهتزاز الثقه بالعمله
الامريكيه الدولار وايضا حدوث ركود
اقتصادي في اكبر اقتصاد في العالم وما
يمكن ان يترتب عليه من تداعياته هو اذا
جرس انذار مما يمكن ان يحدث من عواقب ولا
تقول ان هذا الامر لا يجب ان ينتظر حتى
الموعد النهائي في الاول من يونيو المقبل
لانه كلما اقتربنا من هذا الموعد كلما
بدات التداعيات بظهور هذا الامر ايضا حذر
منه الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن في تدوينه
له اول امس الجمعه حيث قال ان الكونجرس
الامريكي سبق وان رفع سقف الدين 78 مره
عبر التاريخ منذ عام 1960 من بينها ثلاث
مرات فقط في عرض سلفي الرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامبو وهو يشير بذلك الى ان
الجمهوريين
يساهمون في خلق ازمه كبيره في ظل المنافسه
على الانتخابات المرتقبه دون ان ينظروا
الى التداعيات الممكنه ويكون ان ثمانيه
ملايين وظيفه يمكن ان تفقد وان الطبقه
الوسطى هي الاكثر تضرا من مثل هذه الازمه
نعم ايمان مراسل الجزيره كنت معنا من
واشنطن شكرا لك